[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about people but make them small and
bald that's right babies and
specifically is it good to have them
because increasingly people are starting
to think not so much recently public
figures like prince harry and meghan
markle or alexandre ocasio-cortez are
starting to argue that having fewer or
even zero children might be the most
moral and or most responsible thing to
do of course for folks who've always
dreamed of birthing a little tike or two
or a baker's dozen contemplating the
idea of not bringing life to an adorable
monster like this is understandably
upsetting so it's worth asking is having
a kid or even a lot of them a positive
way to pass down your superb head of
hair and green thumb or is there
something irresponsible about bringing
life into this slowly sinking titanic of
a planet let's find out in this
wisecrack edition is having babies
ethical
so how has procreation historically been
regarded well christian morality has
long held that having children if you
can is a good thing in the bible god
tells a bunch of people like adam and
eve and also noah to be fruitful and
multiply and obviously some people do
still take this imperative very
seriously if you don't believe us go
meet some midwestern catholics or just
rent cheaper by the dozen one and two
but it's also an imperative that's been
challenged by philosophers for instance
take schopenhauer a crotchety pessimist
who thought that we may as well be
living in the worst of all possible
worlds and he didn't even live to see
the season finale of hawkeye he believed
reproduction was little more than an
unwelcome side effect of humankind's
endlessly failed attempts to satisfy our
desires a moment of physical pleasure
then i.e doing sex could result in
offspring thus continuing the human race
and the misery of its existence via kids
that will grow up and be just as
miserable as you it's like your middle
school health teacher told you sex has
consequences meanwhile in his book the
birth of tragedy nietzsche paraphrases
the ancient greek wisdom of celenus
which was given to a tragic king by a
man with the ears of a horse it is best
not to be born at all and next to that
it is better to die than to live to be
clear we do not endorse this message and
we hope that selena's friends gave him a
big hug after he wrote that philosophers
call this view that it is bad to be born
or to have children
anti-natalism the most prominent
contemporary proponent of anti-natalism
is the south african philosopher david
benatar we talked about him in our video
on attack on titan if you'll want to
check that out too benatar like
schopenhauer thinks the world is really
really bad but interestingly he argues
that it would still be morally wrong to
bring new human life into existence even
if the world wasn't a greenhouse filled
with farts see benatar thinks that there
is an asymmetry between pleasure and
pain we all know it feels good to
experience pleasure and bad to
experience pain but benatar argues it's
only bad not to experience pleasure if
you're conscious that you're being
deprived of said pleasure like if you
didn't know that this 24 karat gold ice
cream existed you couldn't be sad that
you will likely never have the pleasure
of indulging in it but now you know
about it and we can all be depressed
together conversely it's good not to be
in pain even if we're not conscious of
that lack of pain at all we don't have
to be thinking about how it might feel
to sit on a cactus to be enjoying the
state of non-cactus sitting but now you
are so you're welcome thus the asymmetry
between pain and pleasure bringing
people into existence then gives them
the ability to feel pleasure and pain
and this for benatar is morally bad
because no amount of pleasure could ever
outweigh the wrong we've done to someone
by giving them the ability to feel pain
so thanks mom as it happens benatar
argues our own world is characterized
more by pain than it is by pleasure and
if you don't believe us just ask ben
affleck's face but even in a
hypothetical world where everyone only
experienced pleasure it still wouldn't
be right to bring someone into existence
says benatar that's because he thinks
such a life would be about as good as a
state of total non-existence for this
reason benatar argues having kids can
never be anything other than a selfish
act at one point in his book better to
have never been the harm of coming into
existence benatar even compares having
children to taking hostages as people
can use their children to leverage
better treatment in society one of his
examples is if two women need a kidney
but there is only one available and one
of those women is a mother and the other
is not who does society think should get
the kidney but people aren't all
questioning the morality of baby making
because they've read david benatar for
the most part it's because they've been
watching the news with this crappery
greeting us every night it's no wonder
one in four child free american adults
say they plan not to have children
because of climate change as we all
hopefully know the climate disaster is
being caused by the pollution in
particular the carbon emissions of human
beings it therefore makes sense that
reducing the number of humans would help
the crisis especially the number of
humans in developed countries who are
responsible for the bulk of emissions
for more on how to fix the climate
crisis check out our wisecrack labs
video on carbon capture over the past
200 years the earth's population has
gone from 1 billion people to 8 billion
and it's only going up perhaps it would
be right to see this sort of growth as
unsustainable now exxon is obviously way
more responsible for this large-scale
pollution than you and your honda civic
still individual solutions for combating
or at least mitigating climate change to
some extent have become more well-known
we're all aware we could be reducing our
carbon emissions by eating less meat
flying less often or investing in an
electric car though not a tesla please
never a tesla we know that we should be
buying zero waste products or
conscientiously sorting our recycling
but empirical studies have found that of
all the climate-friendly changes by far
the most effective would be
don't make any new little polluting
machines in other words have fewer kids
if you get rid of your car for instance
you might save 2.4 tons of carbon a year
but if you have one fewer child studies
have argued you save on average
58.6 tons a year this is what harry and
megan are supposedly doing by limiting
their family to only two children which
we have to applaud if the average child
emits 58.6 tons of carbon a year just
think of how much pollution the average
prince emits who knew that ending the
monarchy was such a climate friendly
move but having children might not be
bad just because they're bad for the
planet benatar goes so far as to argue
that having children is bad for the sake
of the children themselves
this makes sense i mean
climate change now maybe you don't think
that existence right now is necessarily
a bad thing i mean uh you can order
sushi while you go to the bathroom and
we're getting two j-lo rom-coms in the
first half of 2022 but you might be able
to agree that existence in the age of
climate change already is or might
eventually become not great even in the
best case scenarios life over the course
of the next few decades is likely to get
really difficult for much of the planet
who's to say that a child born today
wouldn't eventually really vibe with
george bailey i said i wish i'd never
been born it's generally understood that
parents feel it's their duty to ensure
their children have the best lives
possible but who can honestly make that
guarantee today so this is getting
pretty depressing especially if you like
babies or your name is anne gettys this
is what it's all about you know this
sense of joy
that comes with babies so what hope is
there
well some philosophers would argue
plenty
for many arguments like benatars don't
really hold up because human beings just
don't work like that consider for
instance the views of hannah arendt for
a rent every human action always meant a
new beginning people for the most part
don't just do the same stupid things
over and over again for no reason unless
their name is sterling archer lana
introspection is the enemy of happiness
so my advice is don't always work for me
has it though
i don't know that's the beauty rather
they are constantly striving if often
imperfectly to do something new and
hopefully better and this theory of a
rents doesn't just apply to adults it's
also about children children after all
are never simply carbon copies of their
parents they might resemble them in
certain ways sharing similar experiences
backgrounds and proclivities but they
are not identical and therefore they are
able to do things differently or rent
used the word natality to signify this
fact the new beginning as she called it
inherent in birth for rent natality was
incredibly important because it's what
helped save us from disaster and she was
making this optimistic argument after
the horrors of world war ii after all if
everyone really was identical to their
parents if there was no new beginning
inherent in birth then we would always
be doomed to do the same things too set
in our ways to ever stop doing the
things that we know are causing
everything to go wrong luckily that's
not the case i mean just look at the
suburban teens on tick tock posting
videos about why france fanon rips their
lame ass parents would never because
children have the capacity to do things
differently and better than their
parents orent argued the birth of new
children is not only a morally good
thing it's our only coherent source of
hope sure things are bad now but our
children are not doomed to emit as much
carbon as we do they can choose to be
different life in the age of climate
change might suck but that doesn't mean
our children will be incapable of rising
to the challenge nothing of course is
inevitable natality does not mean that
our children are necessarily destined to
succeed they might grow up to host a
youtube channel who put that there it's
not funny it's what i do and i'm i'm
proud of my job i'm proud of this but
from the perspective of the human
species at least continuing to have
children despite everything is the only
course of action that really makes sense
in this view reproduction isn't selfish
it's hopeful so what do you guys think
are children a source of hope or is this
just wishful thinking is it okay to
bring new human life into existence or
would we be doing our children a favor
by never having them let us know what
you think in the comments and if you're
interested in learning more about this
topic check out infinitely full of hope
by tom wyman who just so happened to
write this very video
thanks as always to our patrons for all
your support and be sure to check out
our podcast hit that subscribe button
like you're popping today's birth
control pill out of its pack and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
because i know about birth control pills
because i'm a man